merci Stéphane de rugulier d'être avec
nous et de nous accompagner pendant
cette première demi-heure sénateur là
commission des lois on va évidemment
parler longuement de cette décision du
Conseil constitutionnel d'abord un mot
sur la journée d'hier on l'a vu la
mobilisation est en baisse pour cette
deuxième journée un peu partout en
France est-ce que vous y voyez le signe
d'un essoufflement voire d'une fin de la
mobilisation
le plus marqué si vous permettez c'est
quand même
des factieux qui sont autour du Conseil
constitutionnel pour faire le siège de
notre de notre État de droit et c'est
marques d'intimidation
m'inquiète grandement notamment quand je
vois des responsables politiques comme
Monsieur Mélenchon se réjouir de
l'attitude
des émeutiers c'est quand même le pilier
un des piliers de notre de nos
institutions et je vois dans l'attitude
de Mélenchon
une sorte de du gauche Chavez à la
française ce qui m'inquiète sur ces
objectifs
finaux et ça je pense que l'ensemble des
républicains quel que soit
ce qu'ils pensent sur la réforme des
retraites devrait prêter attention
d'autant plus que la France insoumise
rentrer si j'ose dire dans le Parlement
à l'Assemblée nationale donc quels sont
les objectifs finaux pour vous ah ben je
pense que c'est déstabiliser la
Cinquième République il annonce
clairement il veut une sixième
république donc il veut un climat
insurrectionnel révolutionnaire un peu
comme la terreur de de 1792 à 95 et ça
c'est très inquiétant pour la démocratie
mais également pour l'avenir de la
composition du paysage politique
vous parler de Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a
Olivier matheux que vous connaissez
cette secrétaire général de la CGT dans
les Bouches-du-Rhône il écrit ceci le
Conseil constitutionnel aurait tout
intérêt à se ranger du côté du peuple
tout autre décision serait un acte
contre les travailleurs et nous devrons
en tirer les conséquences qu'est-ce que
vous connaissez cette constitutions
d'abord en droit qu'il y ait
effectivement une dimension politique
dans sa décision c'est tout à fait
logique mais il a deux types de contrôle
de constitutionnalités à faire le
premier c'est le contrôle de constitué
externe sur la procédure qui a été
utilisée où les procédures pour
fabriquer cette fameuse loi et là c'est
du tout ou rien soit il retoque
l'ensemble du texte soit il dit non tout
compte fait la procédure
d'Olivier matheux vous voyez une forme
de pression bien sûr
que vous condamnez bien sûr le Conseil
constitutionnel est indépendant son 9
sages qui doivent et ça a été dit de
manière la plus sereine possible à huis
clos pour ne pas être justement soumis
aux pression extérieures prendre leur
décision mais d'abord sur l'angle du
droit
et vous craignez que ce ne soit pas le
cas vous craignez qu'il y ait une forme
de pression je pense je pense que pas
mal de Français découvrent l'émission du
Conseil continuel je pense il rentre 200
décisions par an quand même donc ils ont
l'habitude bon là c'est un texte quand
même très sensible mais il y en a eu
d'autres sous la Cinquième sous la 5e
République sur la pour finir sur la
mobilisation les syndicats donnent
rendez-vous le 1er mai pour vous ça va
redonner du souffle à la mobilisation
sociale cette journée du 1er mai on
verra bien ce qui est sûr c'est que il y
a une colère sociale dans notre pays et
ça il faut le prendre en considération
et il faut un changement de méthode du
gouvernement il faut apaiser les choses
et il faut réinstaurer un dialogue
social notamment avec avec les
partenaires sociaux et les syndicats on
va revenir sur changeant de méthode mais
d'abord on va parler de la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel qui est donc
attendu aujourd'hui en fin de journée
quels sont les scénarios possibles on
voit ça avec en tant qu'amet
[Musique]
bonjour Quentin bonjour Oriane bonjour
Stéphanie et Quentin tous les regards
sont donc aujourd'hui tournés vers la
rue de Montpensier là aussi ai-je les 9
juges constitutionnels alors on peut
commencer d'abord par appeler qui sont
les membres du coup c'est
constitutionnel voilà on parle des 9
sages effectivement de la rue
Montpensier C9 personnalités nommé pour
un mandat de 9 ans tous les trois ans le
président de la République celui du
Sénat et celui de l'Assemblée nationale
choisissent chacun un nouveau membre
voici donc sa composition actuelle
Laurent Fabius président ce conseil il a
été nommé par François Hollande autre
Premier ministre Alain Juppé a été nommé
par Richard Ferrand en 2019 Jacqueline
Gouraud et Jacques mesard sont deux
anciens ministres qui étaient sénateurs
également à les connaît bien ici au
Palais du Luxembourg eux ont été nommés
par Emmanuel Macron François Pillet
ensuite Michel Pinault et François
Seners ont tous été nommé par Gérard
Michel Pinault il est un ancien juriste
du Conseil d'État nommé au Conseil
constitutionnel en 2016 François Seners
est un ancien haut fonctionnaire nommé
l'année dernière autrement Véronique
Malbec a été nommé par Richard Ferrand
et magistrats ancienne procureur général
à Versailles et à Rennes et enfin encore
une on termine avec Corinne Lucien qui
est une personnalité que l'on voyait
souvent derrière le président de
l'Assemblée nationale aux questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement elle était
secrétaire général de l'Assemblée
nationale au fil des réformes
constitutionnelles en yen les juges ont
gagné de plus en plus de pouvoir
notamment depuis la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 le Conseil
constitutionnel est maintenant de plus
en plus proche d'une Cour suprême sur le
modèle américain qui vient trancher des
débats juridiques autour des
dispositions contestées de tel ou telle
loi alors ce sont donc Quentin c'est
neuf juge qui vont délibérer arbitrer
les recours déposés contre la réforme
des retraites leur décision sera connue
en fin d'après-midi quelles sont les la
question est de savoir si les juges vont
censurer la réforme de retraite ou s'ils
vont la valider entièrement et s'il
censure la réforme ils peuvent décider
de ne censurer que certains articles sur
les vins que compte la réforme des
retraites on pense notamment à l'index
senior ou encore le CDI senior de mesure
qui faisait partie de l'article 2 de
cette réforme c'est deux mesures
pourraient être considérées comme hors
sujet des cavaliers avec une loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
puisque c'était le véhicule choisi par
le gouvernement les députés et sénateurs
de gauche espère la censure totale même
si c'est le scénario le moins probable
ils ont plaidé devant le Conseil
constitutionnel alors eux ils ont
plusieurs arguments pour la censure
complète la limitation des débats à 50
jours les mesures hors sujets que l'on
vient d'évoquer et enfin les différentes
procédures pour accélérer le débat tout
cela bien cela fait qu'il y avait plus
sincérité dans les débats c'est le terme
enfin les sages diront ce soir dans la
même décision s'il valide la tenue d'un
référendum d'initiative partagée ce
référendum également voulu par la gauche
qui vise à empêcher le décalage de l'âge
de départ à la retraite mais alors pour
qu'il ait lieu on le rappelle il faudra
ensuite qui est 4,9 millions de Français
qui signent une pétition Stéphane
lerudulier qu'est-ce que vous retenez
vous dans ces scénarios probable lequel
est le plus probable selon vous écoutez
quand on regarde l'histoire du Conseil
constitutionnel on se rend compte qu'il
n'a rotoqué que 5 à 5 reprises des
textes dans leur intégralité on se
souvient tous de la loi de finances de
1900 79 qui a été un cataclysme dans
l'histoire parlementaire parce qu'il a
fallu vite de nouveau débattre sur cette
loi de finance mais globalement quand on
regarde les jurisprudences du Conseil
consuel depuis 2005 vous avez parlé du
principe de clarté de sincérité des
débats une analyse pas le contenu de
débat il simplement sur la procédure en
tant que tel et c'est là dessus que
Dominique Rousseau que vous allez
recevoir dans quelques instants s'appuie
pour dire il y a une accumulation de
procédures qui ont fait qu'on a voulu
raccourcir le temps du débat mais je ne
pense pas que le Conseil constitutionnel
ça sera un revirement de sa
jurisprudence elle sera un moment fort
comme en 1971
penchera pour rooter l'ensemble du texte
en revanche puisqu'il y a une saisine
blanche de la première ministre sur
l'intégralité des articles effectivement
il y a un risque très fort que au
minimum l'index seniors le CDI senior et
aussi quelques points sur la pénibilité
soit retenue comme cavalier sociaux et
soit sorti du texte et là ça pose un
problème parce qu'en fait on durcit
mécaniquement le texte est toutes les
avancées à caractère social pour que le
texte soit plus acceptable vis-à-vis de
la population malheureusement
sont décousues vont être décousues par
le Conseil constitut c'est le risque et
je pense que c'est cette solution là qui
sera retenue
qui serait à la rigueur celui d'origine
du gouvernement un mot sur le référendum
d'initiative partagé ce que il peut être
validé selon vous on voit que la gauche
on a déposé un deuxième un peu dans la
précipitation parce qu'ils avaient peur
que la formulation qui avait été déposée
la première elle soit après je pense
qu'il y a une chance que ce référendum
d'initiative partagé soit validé par le
Conseil consuel
le premier ou le second mais en tout cas
le premier est-ce qu'il va ce qui va se
jouer derrière c'est la procédure de 15
mois
et c'est un peu une épée de Damoclès sur
l'exécutif on rappelle du 15 mars
et après six mois pour déclencher le
débat à l'Assemblée nationale au Sénat
il faut qu'il y ait deux votes et s'il y
a pas de vote simultané dans les six
mois le président de la République a
comme obligation organiser un référendum
sur ce sujet là donc attention
l'affaire est loin d'être close et c'est
la raison pour laquelle il faut appeler
l'exécutif le c'est bien je pense que le
Président de la République a bien
compris il faut tendre la main au
syndicats et de toute façon une loi
travail sera nécessaire notamment pour
réintroduire les cavaliers sociaux du
plfssr et est-ce que vous quand vous
voyez la composition qu'on rappelait du
Conseil constitutionnel vous vous dites
que c'est un conseil qui sera
conservateur dans le sens où voilà il y
a peu de risques politiques il va pas il
va pas faire des faits de manche écoutez
vous remarquez quand même qu'il y a des
personnalités d'une part politique de
premier rang et aussi des personnalités
juridiques de premier rang donc c'est
effectivement très équilibré il y aura
forcément la dimension politique mais il
y aura surtout la dimension
juridique vous savez le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est d'abord et avant
tout une juridiction ce sont des
magistrats avant d'être des anciens
hommes politiques ou des anciens
fonctionnaires d'État si le Conseil
constitutionnel ne censure pas
totalement la loi Emmanuel Macron n'aura
plus que deux choix soit la promulgate
tel quel soit demander une nouvelle
délibération est-ce que vous souhaitez
vous une nouvelle délibération
écoutez en tout cas je savais dès le
départ nous étions dit que la procédure
utilisée à travers l'article 47-1 de la
Constitution c'est à dire un texte
budgétaire n'était pas la bonne
procédure donc une nouvelle délibération
mais pourquoi faire puisque de toute
façon si on repart sur cette procédure
on est déjà en tant limité donc
attention il y aura un temps également
très limité pour réexaminer le texte non
je pense plutôt qu'il faut qu'il
repartent sur une nouvelle méthode et
déposer une loi travail et après
redéposer un texte sur la réforme des
retrait vous savez je prends l'exemple
de la pénibilité
peut-être repousser l'âge de départ en
retraite mais avant il faut traiter
notamment le critère de pénibilité des
carrières longues regardez un maçon
je prends souvent l'exemple du maçon on
est là en train de dire est-ce que c'est
58 est-ce que c'est 57 mais
pouvez pas le sujet un maçon des 50 ans
commence à avoir des pathologies liées à
sa pénibilité de son travail et donc
c'est surtout sur la reconversion
professionnelle ou sur le tuilage la
formation de nouveaux entrants sur le
marché du travail un espèce de
compagnonnage qu'il faut aider à travers
un texte de loi travail donc d'abord
plancher sur ces sur ces aspects-là
avant d'aller vers une mesure d'âge sur
la réforme des retraites mais sur cette
loi travail parce qu'Emmanuel Macron
souhaite recevoir les syndicats après la
décision du Conseil
constitutionnellement eux vous l'avez vu
ils sont assez mitigés ils disent mais
qui sait si on parle pas de la réforme
des retraites ça n'a pas est-ce que vous
leur dites mais si il faut y aller faut
parler de la loi travail c'est là où
vous pouvez introduire des mesures c'est
là où on peut introduire des mesures
sociales afin de corriger les injustices
du texte initial sur la réforme des
retraites quand vous avez traité
clairement l'emploi des seniors on l'a
dit on la redit
un seigneur de plus de 55 ans
juste un seul exemple sur le
rehaussement de la retraite minimale ça
touchait au départ des millions de
Français puis on s'est rendu compte que
l'enveloppe enfin les personnes
concernées
sont réduites parce que les cas étaient
étaient limités il y a eu il y a eu des
périodes de flottement mais là on est
sur le contenu des débats et puis
derrière n'oublions pas que le Conseil
consuel va aussi juger des moyens
d'obstruction de l'opposition parce que
si nous sommes pas arrivés au terme des
débats à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
aussi parce qu'il y a eu une méthode
d'obstruction dite clairement énoncer
clairement d'une certaine frange de
l'opposition
dans le club on parle du référendumnitif
partagé ce sera à suivre à tout à
l'heure Quentin sur la sortie de crise
politique est-ce que pour vous la
solution d'une sortie de crise c'est un
accord de gouvernement avec les
républicains
écoutez je d'abord il faut un nouveau
cap il faut une nouvelle méthode c'est
essentiel et ça ça vient et ça ne peut
émaner que du président de la République
ce qui est sûr c'est que je ne pense pas
qu'on puisse que Elizabeth band puisse
incarner cette nouvelle méthode
est-ce bien sûr elle sort très affaiblie
de cette séquence il est difficile de
réenclencher un dialogue social avec une
personne qui a tourné le dos à un moment
donné aux organisations syndicales
maintenant un accord de gouvernement ça
veut dire quoi on a des divergences
idéologiques on parle beaucoup de
dépenses publiques sur le régalien sur
les sujets de sécurité d'immigration
donc il faudrait trois ou quatre axes
thématiques sur lesquels la droite
puisse travailler main dans la main avec
l'exécutif ça ne peut venir que du
président de de la République et après
savoir qui porterait en tant que Premier
ministre mais aussi des ministres
régaliens le projet politique ce serait
un gouvernement de mission sur un temps
défini et ça c'est toutes ces questions
Premier ministre on parle effectivement
de d'élargir la majorité vous savez
c'est l'homme du consensus c'est l'homme
du dialogue social oui effectivement
mais au-delà de ça le temps n'est pas
encore venu il y a des en tout cas des
des jalons à poser de la part du
président de la République mais il y a
d'autres personnalités comme Gérald
Darmanin on parle aussi de Sébastien
Lecornu qui sont des personnalités
issues de la droite et je pense que s'il
veut élargir sa majorité il faut
vraiment que ce gouvernement est une
couleur une connotation de droite très
très marquée est-ce que les républicains
ont d'autres choix un accord de
gouvernement on voit les sondages ce ne
sont que des sondages certes pour la
présidentielle il donne leur avancer à
5% oui on a d'autres choix en tout cas
nous c'est pas
il y a un temps pour l'exécutif pour ce
travail peut-être en partenariat avec
l'exécutif mais notre famille politique
elle doit se recomposer elle doit se
refonder au niveau des idées et il faut
très vite se mettre au travail vous
savez je prends la réforme des retraites
je l'ai dit à de multiples reprises la
mesure d'âge 62 à 64 ans elle est
nécessaire pour sauvegarder notre
système de répartition mais c'est
toujours les vieilles recettes qu'on
sortait il y a en 2012 en 2017 quand
j'ai dit il faut réfléchir à adosser un
système de capitalisation au système de
répartition c'était un vrai sujet qui
doit permettre aux républicains de dire
bah il y a peut-être une autre issue on
peut travailler davantage mais aussi on
peut capitaliser pour soi davantage tout
en préservant notre système de
solidarité intergénérationnelle quel
système de répartition sur ces sujets là
la droite doit travailler
idéologiquement pour proposer un nouveau
projet de société alors ça c'est sur le
fond sur l'incarnation est-ce que le
robot qui est aujourd'hui encore le
candidat naturel de votre famille moi je
faisais partie des personnes qui ont
toujours dit il faut déjà travailler sur
le fond avant de voir qui pourra
incarner le nouveau projet
écoutez on verra en temps voulu je pense
que c'est pas lors du jour et ce n'est
plus à l'ordre du jour aujourd'hui avoir
l'actualité dans nos régions pour
terminer on va à Nancy on retrouve
Michael de mots bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous directeur départemental
de l'Est Républicain en
Meurthe-et-Moselle Michael est-ce que
vous êtes avec nous je vous entends bien
bonjour Michael merci beaucoup d'être là
Mickaël on va parler d'un autre sujet
avec vous puisque dans vos pages vous
revenez sur le fléau des trafics de
drogue oui on a l'impression qu'il y a
quand même pas que les retraites qui
sont dans l'impasse aujourd'hui nous
tous les jours au groupe les bras et
elle est républicains monsieur le
sénateur on relate vous le savez bien
les affaires de drogue du trafic de
drogue alors il y a quelques semaines
vous avez interpellé le ministre de
l'Intérieur sur le laxisme supposé de
l'État mais ce qui a plus de 10 ans une
douzaine d'années une quinzaine d'années
votre formation politique est-ce qu'elle
a donné assez de moyens aux forces de
l'ordre pour lutter contre ces trafics
j'ai interpellé le ministre de la
Justice plus précisément parce que en
fait il y a eu des moyens je pense
notamment sur sur Marseille de déployer
il y a eu 300 policiers supplémentaires
trois compagnies de CRS mais le problème
de notre de notre pays sur ces sur le
trafic de drogue c'est en fait la
rupture sur la chaîne pénale on a
l'impression que les têtes de réseau
sont dans une forme totale d'impunité et
quand j'ai alerté mise de la justice
j'ai dit attention il y a des dossiers
sur des homicides des réglement de
compte qui sont classés sans suite par
le procureur de la République et si vous
voulez lutter efficacement contre le
trafic de drogue il faut s'en prendre
d'une part aux têtes de réseau avec des
peines beaucoup plus fermes on parle de
20-30 ans aujourd'hui les peines
prononcées en moyenne c'est de 6 à 10
ans pour la tête de réseau et ces
personnes là continuent à exercer leur
influence sur les quartiers notamment
les quartiers nord de Marseille même
quand ils sont incarcérés il y a
véritablement un premier sujet et puis
deuxième sujet c'est le sujet des
consommateurs effectivement les amendes
forfaitaire mise en place de 200 euros
ne sont pas assez dissuasives un
consommateur pris sur le fait doit avoir
au minimum une amende de 1500 euros en
tout cas c'est une proposition que
j'avais faite et si dorénavant est
récidive et bien c'est une obligation de
soins par rapport à l'addiction vous
voyez donc c'est pas uniquement un
problème de moyen humain et notamment en
termes de sécurité c'est aussi une
réforme de notre de notre chaîne pénale
sur ce sujet
tellement malade aujourd'hui je pense
notamment à ceux qui consomment du crack
dans la région parisienne
là il y a une obligation de soins il
faut les accompagner à sortir de de ce
fléau qui est cette forme d'addiction il
y a deux volets il y a le volet
répréhensif et fin la répression pardon
et quand même quelque chose de fort pour
éradiquer ce fléau parce qu'il faut pas
oublier une chose si il y a des
trafiquants de drogue c'est qu'à bel et
bien aussi des consommateurs qui
viennent ou qui se font livrer
maintenant directement chez eux leur
dose mais après il y a l'obligation de
soins je pense que ça aussi c'est
important il faut essayer de sortir de
l'enfer de la drogue ces personnes là
[Musique]
c'est la Une de l'Est Républicain alors
l'Est Républicain retraite un vendredi
crucial c'est à la Une de votre journal
merci beaucoup Michael de Maud d'avoir
été avec nous à un mot sur Marseille
puisque cette semaine il y a encore eu
cinq fusillades la nuit précédente pas
cette nuit-là qui ont fait 4 blessés
donc un adolescent de 15 ans on a un peu
l'impression que Marseille est en ce
moment dans une spirale infernale
comment on peut faire comment Marseille
il peut faire pour s'en sortir est-ce
que ça passe par des moyens
supplémentaires de la part du
gouvernement est-ce que ça passe par
autre chose les moyens ont été mis il
faut être très clair je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure 300 policiers supplémentaires
trois compagnies de CRS non il faut il
faut travailler sur sur la chaîne pénale
je pense que c'est c'était essentiel
puis après il y a un projet de
requalification aussi
urbaine il faut des enclaver les
quartiers nord il faut un vaste plan de
rénovation urbaine afin qu'on puisse
aussi sortir de cette configuration où
on a l'impression qu'il y a des des Nar
des zones de non-droit à Marseille et ça
ça passe par des investissements massifs
donc le volet sécurité il faut maintenir
effectivement les moyens le volet
surtout judiciaire et le venez
aménagement du territoire un dernier mot
sur ce drame qui a frappé Marseille
l'effondrement d'immeubles rue de Tivoli
8 morts malheureusement sont à déplorer
ça rappelle évidemment aux Marseillais
le drame de la rue d'Aubagne même si
elle est circonstances ne sont pas du
tout les mêmes Marseille est très
marquée évidemment très marqué très
meurtri on a l'impression
de revivre la rue d'Aubagne mais vous
avez bien fait d'insister ce n'est pas
le la même origine l'enquête nous dira
mais on penche plutôt vers une vers une
explosion une explosion de gaz ou une
fuite de gaz
donc voilà mais
là je voudrais saluer quand même les
marins-pompiers le 10 les forces de
l'ordre vous savez on les accâme
beaucoup mais quand on voit qu'ils ont
parce que c'est une une aussi
d'émissions des forces de cette protéger
les personnes
également toutes les partenaires
institutionnels la mairie le Conseil
départemental
la métropole ce sont des acteurs quand
même qui ont essayé de de
d'atténuer le choc psychologique des
Marseillais puis il y a eu cette forme
de solidarité vous savez vous avez eu
des commerçants qui sont venus
spontanément apporter de la nourriture
des Marseillais qui sont venus
spontanément apporter des vêtements
parce que les personnes ont été évacuées
en 10 minutes on leur a demandé à minuit
1h du matin de quitter leur appartement
ils étaient totalement démuni et c'est
cette forme de solidarité qui est aussi
importante vous savez Marseille ce n'est
pas que le trafic de drogue ce n'est pas
que les l'effondrement d'immeubles
malheureusement
c'est aussi des Marseillais que le corps
chaud et qui sont qui sont solidaires et
on pense évidemment à Marseille merci
beaucoup merci
d'être venu ce matin d'avoir été notre
invité dans 20 minutes dans le club
d'étatoires suite de notre émission
spéciale décision du Conseil
constitutionnel on parlera notamment des
conséquences de cette décision sur la
suite de la mobilisation ce sera dans 20
minutes et on parle tout de suite de
cette décision avec notre prochaine
invité c'est Dominique Rousseau qui nous
rejoint